[Music]
hey
everyone welcome to another installment
of harry potter
theory in this video we're going to be
discussing
the order of the phoenix bellatrix
strange
the battle of the department of
mysteries and the death of harry's
godfather
sirius black the battle of the
department of mysteries was one of the
most important in this series
as it catapulted tensions between the
death eaters and the order of the
phoenix it served as one of the
catalysts
for the second wizarding war and was the
time when the lurking followers of lord
voldemort
revealed their true colours just moments
after the battle of the department of
mysteries
was the epic duel between voldemort and
dumbledore
a moment in which the world specifically
fudge
could no longer argue that the dark lord
hadn't returned
however perhaps the most noticeable
aspect of this battle
was the death of harry's godfather
sirius black
harry was probably closer to sirius than
anyone else
he loved the man like a father and he
was one of the last close connections
that he had to his parents however
sirius's death was a bit unusual
in that it is depicted quite differently
from book to film
before we dive into this further it's
also worth discussing
where his death actually occurred as
this comes into play
the department of mysteries is on level
9 of the ministry of magic
and this department is responsible for
studying the mysteries of the wizarding
world
mysteries associated with love space
thought time and death all manners of
things
however perhaps most importantly within
the walls of the department of mysteries
lies the death chamber the location of
the veil
the veil is a bit of an enigmatic object
in harry potter
and if you only watch the movies then
you probably have even less of an
understanding
of what the veil actually is the veil is
an ancient
stone pointed archway that serves as the
barrier between the land of the living
and the land of the dead it's an ancient
crumbling relic
that no one fully understands and is the
subject of much investigation
by the unspeakables though inviting the
archway is a one-way trip
as if someone from the land of the
living passes through it they inevitably
die
sending messages through the veil is not
possible however
when the souls of the dead recognize a
loved one that approaches the veil
it has been expressed that they will try
to communicate when living people enter
the veil
they appear to experience a relatively
painless death
almost as if they are in a high wind
before simply falling in
it's also been expressed that once
someone begins to pass through the veil
they are beyond saving the reason you
need to understand the veil
is that from book to film the veil plays
a bit of a different role
in sirius's actual death first let's
take a look at the book
come on you can do better than that he
yelled his voice echoing around the
cavernous room
the second jet of light hit him squarely
on the chest the laughter had not quite
died from his face
but his eyes widened in shock it seemed
to take sirius an age to fall
his body curved in a graceful arc as he
sank backwards to the ragged veil
hanging from the arch harry saw the look
of mingled fear and surprise on his
godfather's wasted
once handsome face as he fell to the
ancient doorway
and disappeared behind the veil which
flooded for a moment
as though in a high wind then fell back
into place
harry heard bellatrix lestrange's
triumphant scream but knew it meant
nothing
sirius had only just fallen through the
archway he would reappear from the other
side
any second but sirius did not reappear
the book clearly indicates that sirius
black's death was the result of him
falling into the veil
and nothing else falling backwards into
it after being struck by bellatrix the
stranger's curse
however the film adaptation paints a bit
of a different picture
in the film in only an instant the
battle turns from what seems like a
flawless outcome for the order
to one of the worst outcomes possible
the death of sirius
after finishing off lucius sirius leaves
his guard down
for only an instant and in that same
instant
bellatrix lestrange appears avada
kadavra
she yells shooting a gish of green light
toward him
and just seconds later sirius black had
a blank expression on his face
falling backward through the veil this
confuses things a bit
because in the book it's never mentioned
that bellatrix uses avada kadavra
aka the killing curse i'm sure that
filmmakers
just added it in for dramatic effect but
the issue with this particular curse
is that it causes instant death if you
are properly struck with the vada
kadavra
there is no grace period where you are
left to think move
or react you simply die instantly
but in the film after being struck with
a curse that causes
instantaneous death he seems to stay
alive and look around
for a moment before falling backward
into the veil
however the very fact that bellatrix
uses avada kedavra
a curse that we know to kill sort of
suggest that her spell
was responsible for his death where in
reality it was of course the veil
in fact in rowling's original notes for
this scene bellatrix wasn't even
involved
sirius chose death through the veil in
the eu of being attacked by approaching
dementors
this confirms the veil is capable of
killing and that sirius was always meant
to die
by the veil in reality all bellatrix's
spell needed to do
was push sirius backward and for this
reason i think that she most likely used
some sort of
stunning spell unfortunately this is
just another example
of the types of problems that can arise
when bringing novels to the big screen
sometimes in an effort to create
dramatic effect the context of the
original story
is lost so i think that we can quite
reasonably state
that sirius died after being hit by a
stunning spell
and falling into the veil however one
thing that might be on your mind now is
what happened to sirius what happens to
those who fall
through the veil he had reached the
floor his breath coming and searing
gasps
sirius must be just behind the curtain
he harry would pull him back out
but as he reached the ground and
sprinted toward the dais
lupin grabbed harry around the chest
holding him back
there's nothing you can do harry get him
save him
he's only just gone through it's too
late harry
we can still reach him harry struggled
hard and viciously
but lupin would not let go there's
nothing you can do harry
nothing he's gone after falling to the
veil
sirius was dead i don't think that you
can argue that
though i have heard some try he fell
into a relic known to cause death
inside of the death chamber so i think
that his fate is obvious
we can also confirm that sirius did in
fact die because the shade of sirius
appears in the forbidden forest
when harry has the resurrection stone a
shade can only be produced
when someone has truly died like harry's
parents and the fact that sirius appears
destroys any theory that he is somehow
still alive
harry said it as loudly as he could with
all the force he could muster
he did not want to sound afraid the
resurrection stone slipped from between
his numb fingers
and out of the corner of his eyes he saw
his parents sirius
and lupin vanish as he stepped forward
into the fire light
one thing worth noting is that sirius's
soul was spared
it was never stripped of him like those
who suffered their fate at the hands of
the dementors
and this means that his soul went on to
the afterlife
because the soul is immortal in a way
sirius was
live beyond the veil and that's it for
this video
leave your comments down below until
next time it does not do to dwell on
dreams
and forget to live
[Music]
you